dot org
[Music]
[Music]
hello one thank you so much for coming
out tonight for this politics and pros
at Busboys and poets event as we have
the honor of hosting Daniel Hatcher for
his new book the poverty industry my
name is Davis I work with the event
staff at politics and prose and we just
have a few quick notes announcements we
want to make before I introduce Daniel
tonight first off this is a politics and
pros at Busboys and poets event this is
a newish sort of partnership we've had
going on for about a year in which we
are selling books and hosting events and
three of the Busboys and poets locations
so you're here at the 14th of V location
you can also find us at 5th and Kei and
Tacoma so if you grab a calendar you can
see different events that will be
scheduled throughout the city part of
that great partnership is that now
you're in a restaurant and you can order
food and drink at the same time while
hearing a great book talking so I
encourage you to do so and take your
waitstaff well and everything if at this
moment if you'll take out your cell
phones and silence them so we don't have
any unnecessary interruptions after the
event is over we are going to have a
signing table and opportunity to chat
with Daniel and a little bit more but if
you will purchase the book up at the
front of the store that's where we have
the cash register in the bookstore space
also there's gonna be time for Q&A and I
have this handy microphone right here so
if you'll just raise your hand during
the Q&A section I'll come around so that
everyone can hear the questions that are
being asked and also see spanis book TV
is here tonight shout out to them so
you can you can look yourself up on the
interwebs later if you answer a question
ask a question so anyways alright so in
this eye-opening examination of what all
too often happens to Medicaid and
Medicare funds child support payments
and other public assistance designed for
the ill the abuse the vulnerable and the
elderly hatcher exposes how consultants
and entrepreneurs of for-profit agencies
themselves benefit from government
programs beyond the expose Hatcher
offers ways to reform policy so that the
a does in fact reach its intended
beneficiaries Mary O'Hara of the
Guardian says of this book this
meticulous meticulously researched book
Hatcher lifts the lid on a system that
rather than helping the needy Semak Lee
turns them into you quote a source of
revenue Daniel Hatcher is professor of
law at the University of Baltimore where
he teaches the civil apathy clinic
Daniel previously worked for the Merritt
Maryland legal aid Bureau as the
assistant director of apathy as a staff
attorney for legal aid in the Baltimore
child advocacy unit and as a senior
staff attorney for the Children's
Defense Fund
well you please join me in welcoming
Daniel Hatcher
thank you everybody for being here
especially when it's such a beautiful
late afternoon early evening to sit
inside and talk about some important
policy issues
thanks to politics and prose and to
Busboys and poets huge thanks to NYU
press for for the amazing support and
publishing this book I definitely thank
the University of Baltimore School of
Law and the clinical programs there or I
have the honor to teach students who are
representing low-income clients and then
I had the opportunity to learn through
my students and also through through
their clients and I have a couple
colleagues from there who are here today
and are amazing advocates I also
especially thank my past clients I've
learned so much from their stories over
the years and what they're going through
and from an individual basis of seeing
their difficulties and trying to
understand how their problems connect on
a more systemic level so I hope to keep
this a little bit in formalin and just
have a conversation and I thought I'd
maybe start with a comparison and then
back up a little bit with some of the
introduction so it's in New York on
Monday and I was talking about a county
there Westchester County a few years
back there was a small story in the
newspaper about a child whose adoptive
mother died of cancer and apparently the
child had survivor benefits that were in
a bank account and saved about sixteen
thousand dollars the concern with the
press is that the social worker
apparently got ahold of the child's
survivor benefits it got access to the
bank account after the adoptive mother
dies of cancer and took the money so
there's some outrage criminal charges
were brought against the caseworker
right and county officials put out press
releases to talk about you know their
efforts to go after this individual
meanwhile was happening in Westchester
County countywide is this is a county
who has a contract with a revenue
maximization contractor to seek out not
just survivor benefits from from foster
kids in their
but also disability benefits potentially
more and then the county is taking the
money from children in their care when
they're acting under a fiduciary
relationship and we're not just talking
about sixteen thousand dollars in this
case we're talking about tens of tens of
thousands of dollars that the county is
taking from children but no one has been
up in arms about that in part because no
one is known right you know my hope
through getting this book out is to
increase awareness about about some of
the practices that are occurring and I
think with awareness we have the
potential to bring change so in the
poverty industry I'm hoping to expose
and explain several of these revenue
practices where states and state human
service agencies are partnering with
with companies usually revenue
contractors to actually use the
vulnerable populations as a source of
revenue this is happening I think across
the country because states are
cash-strapped
and both red states and blue states
alike across the country have been
unwilling to raise revenue through
general taxation when you see that
occurring you end up having the states
looking for money elsewhere sort of
behind the scenes mechanisms that be
well sometimes even to the point where
they're using their own agencies to
divert funds from the vulnerable
populations I've been looking into these
issues for quite a while both through
past scholarship I've been involved in
some litigation some policy advocacy
efforts and I think it started for me
almost twenty years ago my first job at
legal aid was in Baltimore City and I
was representing kids in the Baltimore
foster care system I had a huge caseload
my first day in court I think I
represented about 16 children and an
afternoon so honestly I still feel some
guilt from that time because I feel like
I could have should have done more for
those kids but I was awakened to what
foster kids were going through in the
system what they were going through
before they came into the system and how
hard it's been for them when they aged
out of care how little services that
they're provided and as the stats are
really lined up against foster children
with foster kids suffer from PTSD
post-traumatic stress disorder twice the
level of Iraq war veterans so this was
then alarming to me went when I realized
that the very agencies that exist to
serve the best interests of foster care
children we're actually finding a way to
use those children as a source of funds
finding a way to seek out disability or
survivor benefits take control of those
monies as representative payee fiduciary
capacity and then divert those funds to
state coffers
I didn't started some doing doing some
work as well with low-income families
and child support issues including
representing low income fathers which
was eye-opening to me to see the
difficulties that they were going
through and I realized that some similar
practices rapping with child support
where states are not only taking
disability survivor benefits from
children but they're taking child
support from children sometimes the same
children you know when children are in
foster care they go after disability or
survivor Bennett's the benefits also
take child support some states I talked
about in the book will take more of
Nebraska as a regulation will even take
burial plots Maryland drafted a
regulation where they'll take even the
earnings of a child if they're old
enough to work so child support then is
diverted from the children's best
interests and I started to learn as well
about vast practices that are occurring
with Medicaid so even more dollars that
are being diverted from intended purpose
so I wanted to try to understand and dig
and try to connect these issues as much
as I can so with the book I try to step
back a bit and try to see how these
interconnections are happening and the
alarm that I'm seeing is that you're
seeing a shift in mission right where
you have state governments and the state
human service agencies that exist to
serve the public welfare are instead
turning their focus on maximizing
revenue and even hiring companies to
help in that process so before I get I
want to discuss through the examples and
a little more detail before I do that so
I don't
I wanted to stress just a couple themes
that I hope come out of the book first
one is that I don't think the book
provides any evidence whatsoever for
arguments to cut aid to those who need
the assistance right through the work
that I've done into the research that
I've done aid is drastically underfunded
in human service agencies are
drastically underfunded in our country
if you have States and governors who are
diverting aid from funds from intended
purpose the answer is it to cut that aid
or cut the aid programs the answer is to
stop the misuse right this isn't
complicated the other thing I hope to
stress and I want to keep making a point
of is I think the vast majority of our
frontline caseworkers in this country
are overworked and underpaid and they're
trying their best to do good work for
their clients and these revenue
strategies that I'm seeing aren't
happening on the ground they're
happening much higher at the state
agency leadership level sometimes beyond
that at the state level where the the
governor's or the comptroller's offices
are directing the practices so to talk a
little bit more about this practice of
how states are using foster children the
way they do this and many states will
will partner with revenue maximization
consultants Maryland does which is the
state where I practice law and write
teach in Baltimore Maryland started with
a an assessment contract where I hired
Maximus to do an assessment to look
statewide and see how could the state
potentially obtain more resources from
children in their care and then that
Assessment Report which which I obtained
through public records requests that
company actually describes children as a
revenue generating mechanism they target
a hopeful increase in the number of
children determined disabled from at
that time the estimate was around two
percent of the population determined
disabled for purposes of obtaining
disability benefits they target a goal
to increase that number from two uppers
to fifteen to twenty percent of the
children and the goal right was not to
provide actually additional services to
help
those children with those disabling
conditions but again to divert those
funds the general state coffers right so
when this when this occurs the agencies
aren't even benefiting fiscally you know
I don't think foster agencies should be
in the business of funding themselves
through taking resources from abused
neglected children but the agents and
agencies themselves aren't even getting
anymore financial capacity because when
they do this the state the states across
the country reduce funding to the
agencies based upon how much money the
agencies take from the children right so
it's becoming a self-funded foster care
system where children are essentially
being forced to pay for their own care
as a means of saving State dollars in
addition to going after disability
benefits are also seek out survivor
benefits from children and survivor
benefits under the Social Security poke
program these are earned benefits when
we work paying into the system we earned
disability and survivor benefits
disability benefits for herself and also
survivor benefits if we have a dependent
after we die it's much like life
insurance so I represented a client a
former foster child in Maryland who had
this issue happened to him
and when he was placed in foster care at
age 12 right after his mother died he
was moved around to several different
placements they couldn't find a
permanent placement for him they put
they located a brother as a possible
placement resource his brother dies they
locate his father and his father was a
potential resource for him to go stay
with and then his father died sorry so
is everyone in this poor kids he's no
longer a kid and his poor kids family is
dying and the foster agency realized
that their father's dies that the boy is
entitled to a survivor benefit they
never tell him they never tell him that
they're applying for the benefits they
never tell him that they're applying to
become representative payee to take over
control of the money and they never tell
him that they were then taking the funds
this money I mean when Alex is named and
Alex aged out of foster care he
struggled ever since he's been homeless
and struggled with unemployment you know
if he could have used this money while
he was in care to plan for his
transition out of care
to think about conserving in about how
he could most use it he always talked
about wanting to learn how to become an
auto mechanic he lost cars but he's
never had a driver's license right you
know and it also could have provided a
an immense connection to his deceased
parent for Alex you know it's not just
the money where you have that connection
from a parent who dies but it could have
provided an emotional connection for
Alex to know his father work paid into
the system and as he's struggling on his
own he could have had that connection to
try to help himself instead the state
took it without even telling him about
it that's happening nationwide on States
and many states willing to take veterans
assistance benefits from kids in foster
care if their parents died in the
military so the list goes on so some of
the language I've sent out several state
FOIA requests and obtain some contract
documents kids are described as s that
of this there are sort of resources on a
conveyor belt being mined being
described as units again as I mentioned
in Maryland a revenue generating
mechanism they're scored and triage to
determine which kids bring in the most
money data mining algorithms algorithms
are subjected to dissection a goal of
increasing the penetration rate of
children whose resources can be obtained
you know and I've seen documents that
are especially concerning as well when
they determine which kids to try to get
to be determined disabled first it's not
based on which kids have the most needs
it's again which kids bring in the most
money right the states will look at some
kind of some complex interaction with
federal funding sources and those kids
who might have other sources of federal
a that's paying for their foster care
right so the state isn't spending as
much money they won't go after those
kids first regardless of their disabling
conditions they'll go after the kids
that's causing the kids States more
money because then that's saving the
state more money when they take the kids
funds I hope them Thank You Sam so it's
all about the money unfortunately not
about helping the children another
example so this is just one maybe
starting with an example where Medicaid
funds are being maximized and some
states are diverting from intended
purpose not all states
so you could even have the same foster
child I thought children who are
low-income and potentially disabled can
also receive in their schools
school-based Medicaid to provide
additional services for their special
education needs and their disabling
conditions so I described an example and
a book out of New Jersey
where the state forces schools to
participate in a program they have a
different revenue contracted there
they're working with by the name of the
public Consulting Group where the states
are required to work with the contractor
to try to maximize the amount of
children who are receiving these
school-based Medicaid claims in the
amount of aid that's received schools
are punished in New Jersey if they don't
meet the target goals by reduction in
school funding from from the state right
and then when after there's equations it
gets pretty complicated as a plug going
to play in terms of how they determine
how much money they're gonna set as
goals obtained for that for the children
to school based federal Medicaid and
then the state in their budget items and
then their and their budget the
Christian Mason administration is
diverting over 80% of those funds from
the school children from the schools to
general state coffers and amounts to
tens of millions of dollars every year
that are literally being taken from poor
or disabled school children to save
state coffers again because the Jersey
is another state like Maryland like all
the states who are unwilling to raise
enough revenue through general taxation
so looking for money elsewhere even
taking money from disabled
schoolchildren New Jersey schools are so
underfunded their schools are now
seeking revenue by selling
advertisements on the sides of school
buses well this is occurring so that's
another example involving children on
the other age into the spectrum our
nursing homes unfortunately in this
country are not doing very well right
the quality of care on average for our
older Americans is not great and in the
United States in some states are much
worse than others Maryland where I live
which is depending on the year sometimes
the richest state per capita sometimes
may be its number
- it's a degrade according to some
reports it was tied I think with
Mississippi or Alabama one of the
poorest states in the country at that
time District of Columbia is doing a
little better in accordingly one of the
least report cuz I've seen getting a
b-grade Virginia as I've looked at that
same report was getting a degrade so
much of this has to do with the nursing
homes writing in attic care has to do
with them unwilling to provide
sufficient staff at the nursing homes so
we have a vast need for better care for
better services more funding to the
nursing facilities caring for older
Americans especially low income older
Americans unfortunately these nursing
homes are often used in some similar
revenue strategies and many states will
then divert the funds from that intended
purpose to provide better care to the
elderly but rather to general state
coffers or some actually municipalities
or counties to it as well at the county
level so one of the examples I described
is out of Indiana where our practice
like this is happening statewide first
I'm using what's called a bed tax scheme
there's multiple revenue financing
mechanisms that are somewhat illusory
where essentially money is moved around
the Medicaid program is supposed to be a
matching grant program right so states
spend their percentage match and then
they claim a match from the federal
government Maryland's is an easy example
because we're a 50/50 match states of
Maryland spends $50 on Medicaid services
on an eligible individual you can claim
an additional $50 from the federal
government so then you're supposed to
have $100 total to serve that low-income
individual for the type of care in which
the claims were were sought what you're
seeing is that states are moving money
around that they'll move money sometimes
to a nursing facility and take that
money right back or sometimes they'll
charge and there's some facility attacks
get the money and then give the money
back so a round-trip with money one way
or another so where the state isn't
actually spending funds and you state
funds but then they can trigger the
claim for federal aid okay that in
itself is somewhat concerning because
it's a loser
what concerns me a lot more even than
that are those states that went then
when they claim the federal aid they're
diverting it to general coffers so an
Indiana that's happening on a statewide
level with bed tax and Indianapolis
they've also found a way where the
Health and Hospital corporation it's
called the Health and Hospital
corporation out of out of Indianapolis
the county there it's a municipal agency
actually they they figured out a way
they started buying up for-profit
nursing homes they started close to
Indianapolis and now they're gone all
over the state of Indiana corner to
corner buying up for-profit nursing
homes because they realized that in
Indiana the way the legislation works as
soon as that becomes government-owned
they could trigger a higher Medicaid
reimbursement rate from the federal
government right well what the Health
and Hospitals corporation is doing is
they're buying the licenses for these
nursing homes and then and then often
they were hiring the very same company
or companies back that they bought the
licenses from to run the nursing home
still so so the care didn't improve at
all and then instead of using the
federal aid intended for better care at
those nursing home facilities the Health
and Hospital corporation used it to
build a multi-million dollar enormous
new hospital system and Indianapolis now
at least that's been being used for
health care purposes you know right and
Indianapolis but it's that's not the
intent right you know that money for
that facility would have normally
occurred through property taxes
referendums you name it you know ways to
raise that revenue instead they're
literally using older Americans who are
languishing and poor care will it take
their funds all around the corner of the
state you know there's people in the
Northwestern northwestern corner of
Indiana our benefit are benefiting at
all from these services from the
hospital in Indianapolis so that's a
concern finally and then I'll pause a
bit for questions there's more examples
and unfortunately this is occurring some
of them I didn't have the length of
space that to get involved into the end
of the book many people know about
prison industrial complex I talk about
the poverty industrial complex many of
the same contractors who are involved in
the military-industrial
blacks are now actually involved in the
poverty industry right you have
companies like Lockheed Martin and
Northrop Grumman who had [ __ ] involved
in child support services I'm lucky
Martin used to have the contract to run
the Baltimore City child support office
now is Maximus on the same company that
also has the contract the state
statewide now Delta State obtained
disability and survivor benefits from
children which the state then will take
from the children so as an example of
the scope of this poverty industry I
mean we've reached a point first word
where you have agencies are after that
are actually don't have the capacity to
monitor their own private contracts and
the contract award process where they're
hiring private contractors to monitor
their private contracts but but an
example of the scope initiated it
started here in DC st. company by the
name of Maximus Maximus had a contract
to help the District of Columbia I'm
trying to max my Medicaid funds for
foster children there were concerns and
allegations brought by the Department of
Justice the US Department does just
awful called the DOJ that there may have
been false claims
so Medicaid claims that were allegedly
filed that were not true to the point of
a settlement agreement with the
Department of Justice that Maximus reads
for these allegedly fraudulent Medicaid
claims of over 30 million dollars
deferred prosecution agreement what was
entered within just a short time of that
same company Maximus gets a contract
with the state of New York to help New
York run its Medicaid fraud program you
know after it was had these allegations
of Medicaid fraud in DC then a short
time of that the same company Maximus
either answer's new contracts or
continues existing contracts with the
Centers for Medicare and Medicaid
Services for over 200 million dollars
worth of contracts and this is the same
federal agency to which those alleged
fraudulent Medicaid claims were
submitted right within a short time of
that the same company Maximus Inc lands
a contract with the Department of
Justice itself the the agency the
Department of Justice are prosecuting
armed are brought charges against them
initially and that was to get the
language here to investigate and provide
analytical support consulting technical
services financial management and case
related professional support during the
investigation and prosecution of
criminal cases right so the poverty
industry industry is expanding I think I
hope there are some red flags that go
off in terms of how both funds are being
diverted from those of us who need it
the most and how the purpose of
government is shifting in this case
again from serving the public welfare to
more of a focus on revenue maximization
finally like I think a really crucial
theme for us to remember through all
this I used the term vulnerable a lot to
talk about these populations but we're
all vulnerable right you know we're all
interconnected we're all interdependent
on each other and with the government
institutions that are supposed to be
serving us we're all pretty much one
paycheck away from poverty if not closer
so we need to remember when a foster
child in West Baltimore is harmed it
harms all of us right and not just from
a moral perspective but financially even
if you just think about the finances
when that child then does worse and has
a harder time when they age out of
foster care and is more likely to become
homeless and more likely to become
dependent on the public welfare system
and more like to becoming car serated
right unfortunately the number of former
foster children who are involved in the
criminal justice system is just huge we
all pay the cost so I hope you remember
all that and we try to help the most
vulnerable among us
[Applause]
well uh thank you for being here I'd
love to hear what you say
but what I have to ask you about and it
didn't fall into anything if you said
just yep with you it might be in the
book nonetheless so I just say if I'm a
homeless advocate as I celebrate or
shall I say hella great ten years this
month so when it comes to poverty
pimping you know let's be frank you know
that's the poverty pimping I have to ask
but what you have to say you know just
about the whole idea of most fun Roper
versus least vulnerable and as as an
advocate you know I've seen where city
government over cross met several
administration's not just one so it's
not just mayor Bowser you know but the
different administrations I've been
reluctant to help able-bodied homeless
adults to remain in the city and to find
living wage jobs and affordable housing
it's all been about permanent supportive
housing you know and I personally think
that the the constant focus on the most
vulnerable is is in some ways to cover
for we want to aid gentrification we
don't want to address the elephant in
the room as a friend to hear of my likes
to say you know we don't want to address
the fact that it takes 30 dollars an
hour to live in DC as a single person we
don't want to address you know the high
rent the low wages those sorts of things
and and so there's we own work force
innovation opportunities active federal
law that requires city governments to do
better at connecting locard to art to
employ people you know to living wage
jobs and my experience has been that it
always takes of federal law a federal
initiative to make DC do anything better
and so now we're starting to brainstorm
on how to conduct a vod's to jobs we're
just getting started and and it was a
lot of reluctance and a lot of
nonprofits who really would much rather
keep serving the disabled you know
a lot you know but it has you have any
insights there on out now profits when
it keeps something to disable because
there are lifelong cash pals to go onto
permanent supportive housing can they'll
be helped so today they died whereas a
baaad get put into a job no longer be
dependent on the system and you have any
insights there
well great comments and great questions
and you're right I mean I think we could
talk for several days you know about
about these issues and it's a great
discussion I agree with with much of not
most of pretty much everything you've
said I guess to start what I would I
what I think is you know you alluded to
this as well these practices and these
these different ations that you're
saying they're happening in red states
and blue states
I hope first you know I think we can all
disagree about the best structure or aid
programs and I think debate and dialogue
and disagreement are a good thing is
what our country's all about I hope we
can all agree regardless of our politics
or viewpoints that when you have public
aid develop an intended for specific
purpose that money should be used as
intended
right but what you're hinting at I mean
there's so many and interconnecting
systems that are working around
individuals and often not working well
I've done a good amount of work with
individuals who were imprisoned in them
when they they leave in prison to try to
reenter society and they're impacted by
a lot of the issues that you're talking
about talk about a population is not
viewed from a political favorable lens
right and I've worked with a lot of
those individuals also a child support
obligation so they're labeled both as
you know X prisoners and then B dad's
right you know so not the most
politically popular group when you're
trying to help those folks but they need
assistance and the labels are not
accurate most of individuals who are
labeled as debt broke or off and I'm
sorry as deadbeats are often dead broke
I'm are somewhere in between and again
you know this is this child support
practice where they're going after money
that's actually taken from the children
it doesn't even benefit for the children
our states are forcing poor mothers
disputa mothers have custody but not
always forcing poor mothers to soup poor
fathers for money that doesn't even help
the children and their son
look at you know what are these term
fragile families young fragile families
when they have children at a young age
and there's potential for these families
to work well together and to do well for
their children and even if they don't
end up living together to co-parent well
but again when you force a poor mother
to sue a poor father that's not going to
do much for that fragile relationship
and if you have a father that's coming
out of prison and he's trying to get
back on his feet and and live above for
you know and regular economy but then he
has twenty thirty thousand dollars in
child support debt owed to the
government his license is suspended
because of the child support right again
oh did the government much of it right
and then if he does land a job if he's
lucky enough to find an appointment
despite the criminal record I mean those
are difficulties in itself as soon as he
starts to work sixty-five percent of his
wages will be garnished right so a lot
of the low of the individuals in that
case will quit you know and they'll work
underground so there's banding some
reports that actually look at that form
of child support enforcement against
low-income populations like that
especially when the money isn't routed
to the children can actually cause an
increase in criminal activity and a
decrease in people working in the
above-ground economy thank you one of
the one of the most powerful things
about your argument is that it seems
that what that what you're saying is
that all of these practices are legal or
the or the vast majority of them are
legal and so it's very interesting to
think about what sort of solutions you
would you would propose in that context
you know in in in these systems
practices often can be sorta humanizing
I mean that that you're really talking
about a system where people are being
moved around like like beans they're
being counted like beans and if that if
that is for the most part lawful be very
curious about how about where you think
we should go from here it's a great
question I do think unfortunately some
of the practices are likely within the
realm of legal although
I will still you know I'm stubborn I
think many of them are not legal the
practice regarding foster children where
foster care agencies are taking the
children's funds there's a legal
question that has not been really
resolved across the country that it's a
breach of fiduciary obligation right you
know the state is taking on a fiduciary
role both as the Guardian initially in
their state role and as the foster care
agency and then when they take on the
role as representative payee to manage
the children's money that's a fiduciary
role much as I kept your administrator
of an estate so if you have a state that
takes on that fiduciary obligation and
says we're gonna take the child's money
and apply it to pay back state cost that
the child has no legal obligation to pay
for how is that not a breach of
fiduciary obligation now it hasn't been
decided yet but I hope people will bring
claims to that effect regarding some of
the other practices child support
unfortunately you know that when when
the states are taking child support from
children that's under federal and state
law I think that's a policy that
hopefully will change it's it's a failed
effort at what's called welfare cost
recovery and one of the past legal
journal articles I wrote I provide both
the policy concerns and the legal
analysis also just from a pure fiscal
standpoint right even if you're just
looking at how are the states doing and
taking this money from children to pay
back the cost of welfare or foster care
when you look at the numbers the states
are very likely spending much more in
administrative costs than they are
collecting because the parents are poor
right you know they're not gonna be able
to collect these dollars so they're
spending much more than they're
collecting let alone the harm that
they're causing to the children to the
families and to all of us with Medicaid
I I do think there needs to be some some
stronger legal analysis to look at
whether these practices are lawful right
you know the core purpose of Medicaid is
to help States provide additional
medicaid services right it's supposed to
be this mansion grant program so when
you have a state like New Jersey is
blatantly diverting funds to general
coffers I don't see how that's legal you
know like so what's what I think is
happening is this has been known about
for many years
part of it is capacity or federal
agencies don't have the capacity to
track what states are doing off
the state budget processes are not
transparent and then it gets even harder
because much of this in some states is
happening at the county level so it's
hard enough to figure out what the
states are doing with their money but
then you look county by county what
they're doing and it's amazing since you
really try to follow the money
but I do think that some of these
problems the agencies currently have the
capacity they wouldn't even need to be
regulatory change they just need to
decide to enforce what's already there
and make it clear that if you have
Medicaid thawne's claimed on behalf of a
nursing home resident that those
Medicaid funds are supposed to be used
for Medicaid purposes for that nursing
home resident it's not complicated so I
hope that will be the case in children
and in dehumanizing them and turning
them from actual people into units or
revenue streams can you look backwards a
little bit for me and kind of explain
the evolution of the language and the
evolution of the treatment because we
know that when they first started the
programs they were thinking in terms of
children so was it like you know welfare
reform was when it first started to ship
when it turned into black grants or at
one point that states start viewing them
as less than human
that's a great question you know what
point is is it's a harder answer you
know what I've seen with the particular
practice of states looking to obtain
resources from foster children much of
that terminology at least I think is
coming in when the companies have come
in and initially the companies you know
we're able to to entice many and many of
the foster care agencies and first at
the agency level and state level into
these revenue contracts because they do
it on a contingency fee basis right you
know a number of children that they
could obtain benefits from and then the
state could take the children's money
the companies to take a cut you know of
that as a contingency fee and these are
businesses you know they they exist to
make a profit that's their purpose
so they're using terminology in their
contracts that sound like that you know
like in you know and that's the case
with Maximus where the describe children
as a revenue generating mechanism
well and the Secretary of the Maryland
Department of Human Resources he
testified against one of the bills I
worked on it in Maryland you know we've
worked on legislation to try stop this
practice three years now and and the
agency has testified and blocked it
he's time so the secretary of Department
of Human Resources stood up and response
to one question he described like you
know foster is like a business you know
like and I think that's pretty
unfortunate statement for him to make
because it's not a business like I mean
the mission matters right you know like
when and when we're trying to maximize
revenue rather than to maximize the
public welfare of children or for all of
us right we're harmed and you're seeing
that happen you know across the country
there is there is a good story in the
New York Times just earlier this week
about this occurring and the area of
Public Safety both with you know 911 and
amethyst isn't like in the harm that
happens as a result of that I've been
kind of living this my whole life
okay I'm a disabled lawyer and I would
say that the nonprofit's are doing the
same thing as you're talking about
okay and I'll give you an example
there's two examples one is legal
services and one is the protection and
advocacy network that is across the
country that's federally funded okay
both locally I'm talking about Northern
Virginia where I've been working for the
last 30 years as an advocate
you have legal services that's receiving
funds to help people with disabilities
you have the PNAS
getting funds to help people with
disability but when I'm a disability
lawyer and I need accommodations or
whatever could work at an agency forget
it they're not hiring people with
disabilities of those agencies to do the
work to help our people help us and you
know it's we need to look at ourselves
first yeah I never get off and in
Virginia they live at 80 percent of the
poverty level so we're not like doing
real great but you know this is the
problem I think the federal money comes
to help a population you should be
hiring should be hiring people in DC to
work should be training people in DC to
work with the people in DC you should be
hiring disabled people to work with
disabled people but they're not for
hiring middle class mostly white people
to do these jobs and these are great
comments and I think they're wonderful
comments and and you know look and I
mean I was a legal aid lawyer years I've
worked with several non-profits you know
but like with advocating with them and
I've sometimes I've seen the process
even where you have multiple
organizations going after grants if
there's a limited amount of money that
you can actually have competition going
after the money and we need to remember
in that case as an advocate that not to
lose sight of the goal right it's not
about us it's not about growing the
organization and it's about working
yourself out of a job and sometimes
people forget that again you know
mission matter so I think it's a
wonderful point thanks for being here
thank you for being here yeah sounds
like what we need is an Inspector
General to investigate the foster care
system with that help yes and there have
been reports in the past both both with
Medicaid and some of these other
practices with the foster care practice
I'm talking about there really has not
been a look
from the General Accounting Office or
all the Office of Inspector General's
there is some discussion I'm actually
participating on a discussion with the
Social Security Advisory Board in just a
couple weeks and July where they're
looking at this issue regarding SSI
benefits so I'm hopeful and I've had the
opportunity to work with Amy hartfeld
you know on some wonderful advocacy on a
potential federal bill with congressman
Danny Davis out of Illinois who might be
looking at a likely bill that could be
introduced to help fix this problem but
I agree like you know like we need a
look about what's really happening with
these children's funds and particularly
with the use of the revenue contractors
about how not just I mean I think them
taking the money is bad right you know I
don't think this should be occurring but
the process that they're going through
that they're targeting the children just
based on how much money rather than the
disabling need you know there's some
there's some real concerns and some of
some of the things that are happening
with the Medicaid program using the
using various financing tools like
what's something called an upper payment
limit there's actually incentives for
states to pay less to its health care
providers so then they could take
advantage of a gap between the actual
Medicaid payments to say nursing homes
or hospitals as a server
disproportionate share of a part of the
poor pay them actually less so then they
could take advantage of the difference
between that Medicaid payment in the
upper payment limit and then some of
those states will that divert that to
unintended uses Oregon was doing this
we're using Medicaid funds to fund the
entire state public education system now
I think public education is a good thing
you know right you know but that's not
the way those funds are supposed to be
used from trying to solve homelessness
with my friend Eric chef talk here in DC
I've been on audit for over 30 years
used to work with Mitch Schneider but
you educated me tonight because we're
told the home was Sur addicted to drugs
and alcohol they're mentally ill they
lost a job their family broke up no what
I learned tonight is some of them are
coming through the foster care system
we're not getting the benefits into
becoming homeless
right and there's let's take one more
point there's a wonderful opportunity
right now
with conserving these sons for foster
children just last year the federal
government enacted Obama signs something
called able act right that allows for
children who receive SSI benefits
disable disability benefits for four
children those funds can be conserved
and 529 a plans right these are these
are the same sorts of saving vehicles
that we use now for 529 plans for
education savings now they're opened up
where disabled children can use those
benefits to save in these expanded
savings plans 529 a not just for saving
for college for education but for really
a whole host of other types of services
that that child may need to serve to
meet their disabling needs and to then
become independent as they become an
adult right so this is available right
now foster children aren't able to
benefit from Nexus estates you're taking
their money right we just need the
states to stop taking those funds and
then kids can save those monies you know
to put their own money to plan for their
future and not just the money but it
could add that money could then trigger
a planning process right where the
children could be engaged with the
social workers to think about how do
they most want to use and conserve their
funds for their future care and they can
learn financial literacy through the
process and feel empowerment you name it
I mean it's unlimited in terms of a
resource that's really going to waste
right now dan thank you again for your
book of you and I have worked together
on the issue relating to foster children
but this book has helped put that in the
context of a larger poverty industry
which i think is a very important way
for us to frame a lot of the issues that
you're talking about and my question to
you has to do with culpability in shape
you know what we're talking about is a
rather insidious practice nationwide of
basically stealing from poor people and
we've worked together specifically on
the social security issue but I'm
wondering in your experience in writing
this book and investigating these
practices and in different communities
relating to different federal benefits
you introduce this talk by talking about
the reason that some of this is
happening is because states are
cash-strapped
because taxes are low right so
theoretically what you're talking about
is a problem that's been imposed upon
states who become desperate and scramble
for any money they can get their hands
on and it's easiest to take money and
reach into the pockets of poor people
who might not be represented you might
not know their rights but I'm wondering
if you number one if you see that the
tax problem is potentially solving this
or whether you think it's so insidious
that it's sort of seeped into the moral
fiber of the agencies that were that
we're talking about practicing these
things and what your experience was of
speaking to people who had a sense of
shame about what they're doing about it
being morally wrong and morally bankrupt
to practice using that right good
questions and great questions and I do
think it's a horrible practice you know
again I want to stress like I think
frontline caseworkers are doing this you
know they're not the ones who often even
know about the practice is happening
much higher up using a you know with the
agency at the secretary level in
Maryland you know this is someone who
has a business background there comes in
but you know to be fair to him it was
happening before he was there as well
too this was happening both on the
O'Malley administration now under the
Hogan administration and Maryland so
this is happening again in blue states
and red states alike I hope that states
well well I don't think the latter low
of revenue the states in the states
unwilling to raise their taxes
sufficiently raised but to raise enough
revenue and Taxation through general
taxation and a fair means I don't think
that's imposed on states you know that's
a decision that they're making and then
they're looking for money elsewhere so
and I also like we talked a little bit
about privatization I have my own
concerns with privatization some
significant concerns but the thrust of
the book is not looking at that as much
because the end of the day it's the
state leaders who are determining the
scope of the contracts and the purpose
of the contracts and how the money is
used rights as our governor in Maryland
who decides after they work with this
company maximized obtain more resources
from children as the at the highest up
levels
we're gonna take that money and then
divert it to state coffers I want to say
too I mean I think another red flag that
I hope comes out of the book you know on
the same theme in terms of state control
there's been an increasing number of
proposals over the years to increase
what are called block grants right and
you know Ryan has proposed this before
Trump Eve even on his website wants a
block grant to Medicaid program the book
being as objective as I can
provides I think very strong evidence
that block grants are a horrible idea
right you know if you have even if you
thought they might be a good idea in the
first place right you know but but under
the the evidence that comes out if you
have governors who are using his
illusory shell games to move money
around and then diverting those funds
from intended purpose under a complex
regulatory framework from the federal
government right what's that governor
gonna do if he or she is provided a
blank check you know it says here you
know I hope you help the poor right when
it's a state that's cash-strapped and is
revenue you know you're not going to see
more money going to those who need it
you're gonna see greater waste much much
greater waste I love a block grant store
to occur I I just want to echo others
and thank you for what seems to be
extraordinarily an important work thank
you so much you can pass on this if you
want when the governors calculate that
they can play these games I think
they're calculating that if what they're
doing becomes public the citizens in
their state are not going to vote them
out in horror I think it's I think it
speaks horribly about our culture and
our country at this point in time I
wonder if you have any comments on that
sure well apart I do hope awareness
matters that has become more where these
practices that we will be outraged to
the point where we hold our elected
officials accountable to do what's right
and to use money intended for the
vulnerable that's really help help the
vulnerable but unfortunately too often
the most vulnerable
among us don't have a loud voice in the
political process I think we're all
responsible for that to help increase
that voice as we become aware and help
those individuals are even more
vulnerable than us become more engaged
in the process to work together I mean I
know this sounds a little bit like a
kumbaya moment but but you know like I
do think we're all connected right and
we need to remember that we're all
vulnerable we need to work together
again you know what how a child is
impact I'll foster care childhood then
is impacted in Baltimore affects all of
us and we I hope we can start to realize
that again you brought all of our
attention over here oh there you brought
to my attention a lot of the murky
practices of different federal
organizations and even private
organizations with the certain shadowy
games that they play in essence to
create revenue do you believe that
regulation or more oversight could
tackle this issue or has it become such
a large problem both on the federal and
local level I'm optimistic that we can
we can fix and approve these problems
it's not gonna happen overnight
right you know but I do very much think
that we can improve these sometimes it
will require more you know it sounds
like a dirty word in some populations
but to say more regulation but to
clarify regulation and clamp down to say
like if you have Medicaid funds that are
claimed for a poor older Americans and
then that money is intended to help that
poor older American right I think that
is already present we just need to make
that more clear same thing with the
practices that are using foster children
child support is is going to take a
broader change because there's both
federal and state law I actually you
know I I know that many of the leaders
of child support agencies around the
country agree with what I'm saying they
realize that much so much of what's
called child support that is actually
owed to the government isn't being
collected and when it is being collected
that it's harming kids and there there's
an effort at the federal level to start
to improve
rules with the federal office of child
support enforcement some very good
progress along those lines at the
federal level the problem then is going
to be able to get the states to act on
those opportunities right because much
of what's happening at the federal level
is giving States options that they could
take to make improvements so it then
falls again back to us to inform our
state leaders about why these changes
are helpful and necessary you know in
Maryland again as an example one of the
things that Maryland could do this gets
a little complex but the way in which
they collect child support for
low-income populations met oftentimes
the most that they get is through tax
intercepts usually the money went
there's sometimes money that's owed to
the government and some owe to the child
because of a parent was receiving cash
assistance for a while affair or for
shelters and foster care for a while and
then some of the government some owe to
the family usually the family gets their
money first families first policy
there's a big exception to that through
tax intercepts right which is the most
successful way that they go after the
money
so there's legislation in Maryland that
was simply going to say if this money is
collected through tax intercept let's
pay the kids first if the money is owed
to them to pay the kids in the family
before the state takes theirs we're not
wasn't even telling the state you have
to give away your obligation like the
amount that's owed to you but just pay
the family first and again that the head
of the state Child Support Agency of
Maryland stood up and testified against
that bill and actually made what I
thought were incorrect statements saying
that that the agency was giving up this
money when it just wasn't the case it
was just shifting who collects first I
know that gets a little too much detail
but we need to be aware some of this
gets to be complex so we need to be
aware of what's occurring and then and
then hold them to be accountable for
doing the right thing first of all I
want to thank you for the work that
you've doing like other people have I
heard you on WPF W shout out thank you
yeah WP SW and I was intrigued by the
things that I heard I was disappointed
but not surprised I have a child that is
now an adult that is disabled and the
challenges that I went through to get
Social Security for a known disability
that he'd had since he was very small
was very complicated and hard to hear
that states are going through nothing
and getting this speaks to me because
I'm a retired federal employee that of
collusion the Social Security
Administration knows this is happening
Social Security Administration for
whatever reason is colluding with the
states to make this happen and I would
argue and I don't I'm going to buy your
book but I would argue that there is
sufficient law and regulation in place
now to hold that make this practice stop
I figured that this is my question to
you when you're dealing with situations
like this this is we always want to say
well the states are at doing X and the
states are doing why are the
municipalities these states are doing
nothing it's individuals who are making
calculated decisions and until we have
individual accountability as us on the
young lady said over here nothing will
change you you say you're hopeful
because I understand the politics of
this that these corporations pay the
legislators who then make sure that
their interests are taken care of
because you follow the money both up and
down until we get campaign finance
changes or how or political officials
get their money you cannot stop the
corporate influence on these and this is
just for them low-hanging fruit what are
your comments to the political aspects
and the companies actually controlling
the politicians by money well first I
agree with you with when you say
when I used the phrase the state right
the state is made up of people and I do
think that the responsibility lies with
our state leaders who are aware these
practices are occurring sometimes our
initiating on that now sometimes they
inherit now and continue from prior
administrations but that doesn't make it
okay I've heard the excuses in Maryland
when I worked in legislation and
Maryland try to stop the practice of the
foster agency taking resources from
children well other states are doing
this too
I mean how they even use that as a as an
argument is beyond me so other states
are doing bad stuff that makes it good
stuff I mean I don't think that works
but I'm hopeful you know like I refuse
not to be you know I guess and like I I
think as we increase awareness I think I
open all of us here and beyond us as we
become aware these practices are
occurring we can let our elected
officials know that we know and try to
help stop those all right with the one
particular process that you mentioned
how the agencies are taking resources
from foster children there doesn't have
to be a legislative change could be you
know we could simply very much fix it
through through legislation but the
agency could do it right now or the
states could do the right thing right
now right you know so I hope that people
become aware of what needs to happen and
I'm very much helpful because the Social
Security Administration is starting to
look at this you know I'm gonna
participate in this on panel discussions
Ally twelve that I think is occurring
including with elected officials from
Congress and folks have been former
commissioners and of the Social Security
Administration so I'm hopeful but you're
right it's an uphill battle
good evening I want to echo everyone
else's sentiment and thanking you for
being here and thank you for the
important work that you're doing my
question involves whether the motivation
that a lot of the states are using to
[Music]
with these practices to pursue these are
these revenue strategies is really one
based on past wrapped particularly
looking at the state of Maryland
there's definitely Annapolis has
definitely had an appetite for
increasing taxes particularly with
Governor O'Malley with income tax
increases gas tax increases and some
county governments increasing property
taxes so in states that are fiscally
more prosperous in a sense and have had
the means to raise revenue through taxes
is the issue that really one of revenue
shortage and trying to get these funds
but more of a fundamental issue of
morality priority and yeah basically a
moral issue that some people just don't
matter and in addition to that could it
also be influence from lobbyists they're
corporations that are benefiting from
these practices so in that sense it
might not necessarily be a cash-strapped
state but just a system in itself that
is broken well it's both I do think that
priorities are incredibly important and
unfortunately when a state is facing
lean budget times the services for those
who need state assistance the most are
the first services to get cut and I
think that's very unfortunate because
again it hurts all of us
but I do think you know like when we
could have a long broad discussion about
this you know if you look back through
history the level of Taxation in which
states have been willing to to use again
to raise revenue through general
taxation is much lower and that has been
and in the past and we're not expanding
growing more complicated society right
there are greater and greater needs we
need government you know for this and
government needs to have funding to
provide the services that we need so I
hope at some point taxes don't become a
dirty word anymore I mean I know that's
you know probably even more pie in the
sky than some of the other comments that
I made but but I hope so you know pain
taxes the patriotic it's one of the most
patriotic things we can do we have about
time for three more available around for
public office after the less
[Laughter]
you've thrown a lot of problems at us
and they don't seem to be all of the
same cloth I mean the
conflict-of-interest problem with the
state or a private agency serving as a
representative payee at the same time
that they're supposed to be protecting
the interests of that client seems to be
a very significant problem but there's
an easy fix for that there should be an
easy fix right right whether it comes
from the federal government or from the
state government or the courts right or
the courts and yet the politics of
social welfare is often being addressed
by issues around guaranteed income we
could avoid all of this if we just got a
check for everybody for a certain amount
of money and see how they can think or
swim on their own with that entitlement
you haven't mentioned that example of a
solution but I think that is one of the
elephants in the room when problems like
this do get raised the privatization
issue you've identified but sort of
didn't put that front and center here a
script and I'm just wondering how
whether all these issues ought to be
addressed in a more comprehensive way
maybe even in terms of what the
democratization of the human service
planning ought to look like at a at a
community level or whether we should be
tackling these one by one based on the
interests of various groups I mean just
in the comments that you relisted it
here
some people are saying you know people
with disabilities have some special
advantages over general welfare clients
and I'm just wondering how having not
looked at your book how to frame the
issues so that we're actually not just
muddying the waters further or catering
to the strongest interest groups but
actually creating a more humanistic
society like apparently exists in so
many other social welfare societies
where we can count on the government to
be more protective of the public's
interests excellent comments and aiming
to respond to those in right I mean
you're talking about a multi ball volume
set right so my hope with the book is to
spur discussion much like you're
initiating and I think that kind of
discussion and disagreement amongst us
there's a good thing you know we need to
start a dialogue there's a phrase and
I'm probably going to butcher this but I
think it was a nice aim phrase you know
I saw it on the internet so it must be
true was something on lines of you know
like you had an hour to fix any problem
he's been to fifty first fifty five
minutes trying to understand the problem
right so too often we are too quick to
want to rush forward before which really
stop sit back and look about what's
happening so most of the book is looking
at the problem one set of problem not
even all the problems right so one one
set of them and I hope that does spur
much-needed discussion than to think
about how we can start solving some of
these maybe one you know and my future
writings I want to continue to do that
but much of what you're talking about
are things I'm thinking about and it's a
hard discussion I do think some of it
should be simple that you know even
again like when we disagree how to
structure programs for vulnerable
populations we ought to be able to agree
that money that is structured already
put forth is that created with intended
purpose that money should be used as
intended right we regardless of our
politics we should be able to agree that
money
symbian diverted from intended use but
thank you for the questions thank you
thanks again Dan for this great to see
you Debbie there's so much to be
outraged about in this book and I'm not
a lawyer as you know but how can it be
legal you know there are so many broad
issues but just on this somewhat
narrower issue of states becoming
representative pays for safe foster
children but children in plastic right
and not even telling them taking all the
money in your book you mention one acara
bULOG sample of a child should have
inherited or did inherit a home that was
a habit for Humanity home of a right out
of North Carolina and and the
representative pay payee repeat the
state I guess refused to pay the very
small Mort about $220 mortgage for his
habitat in Humanity house so that could
have been an asset for that child that
was lost for that reason he would have
aged out of foster and had a home how
could this be legal and is there a you
know a litigation strategy that's
possible you know that finds the right
court to take this to or something I
love that question and I don't know how
it's illegal I don't think it's legal
and I do think there are litigation
strategies we've I've been involved in
and some pretty substantial litigation
and Maryland both representing the child
I described earlier Alex with my clients
and then I also involved as I was
co-counsel for amici in a case where the
Maryland legal aid Bureau representing a
child named Ryan and in that case we had
some success actually in Maryland where
we did find their Court of Appeals which
is the top about court Maryland found
that the foster agency was violating
foster children's constitutional due
process rights by failing to provide
notice they didn't go further I wanted
to go even further and find that their
breach of fiduciary obligation they
didn't go
there but at least you know they found
that this was a violation of
constitutional due process rights and
that's significant you know now what
notice is provided and that the
attorneys for the children receive that
notice they can challenge the state when
the state seeks to become representative
payee and they could put forth a family
member a pro bono organization you could
have a child advocacy organization
serving and I as a rep payee
representative payee in a voluntary
capacity who really represents a child
and the child's money the way it's
supposed to but I agree you know I think
it's illegal you know there are many
other layers of this legal argument but
the easiest one and probably the
strongest argument is breach of
fiduciary obligation right you know and
I hope that more lawyers across the
country bring these claims
most people don't know what's happening
and when they do know what's happening
unfortunately another part of the
problem is as many of the in many of the
states the foster children don't have
lawyers they have advocates but have
guardian ad litems who aren't lawyers
and they can't file legal claims or when
they do have lawyers many of the lawyers
are overworked you have huge caseloads
so to take on a case like this takes an
enormous amount of time so that's part
of the challenge but I still that
doesn't mean I don't think we should try
right so I great question and I do hope
that we both try to improve this through
policy advocacy and through legislation
and through litigation to bring the
cases forward thank you you'll ask
questions all right one more I'm sure
you won't like this but I have to say I
I'm unable to remember when I've seen
such a combination of brilliance
compassion humility in one person it's
quite amazing thank you for being you
thank you
I just do what my mama tells me to do no
III appreciate that comment but I it's
it's you know look you know you know I
think you know I try to work hard you
know and I care about things when I see
issues you know I can't not unsee those
issues that I I've encountered you know
I just again I said earlier I still feel
guilt that I didn't do enough for the
children I represented years ago but
it's you know it's it's the vulnerable
populations who are dealing with these
issues who are the heroes you know when
I see like you know foster kids who can
go through the circumstances that they
go through and come out and find some
level of success and happiness and and
work forward and care about others I
mean I mean that's heroic you know I'm
just trying to report the facts you know
but but I do appreciate the comments
very much well thank you let's think it
one more time Daniel think one more time
for coming out
[Applause]
I am sorry for the fascinating
conversation you'll want to purchase the
book so if you can do so up at the front
of the bookstore and we'll be here later
after to continue signing or thank you
so much